hello carlos carlos good to see you as
always good to see you again soon
justin
i wanted to talk about
how
exciting this season is for you and for
ben because at the end of season two
like that was the ultimate cliffhanger
man that was incredible what was it like
for you to be able to actually play this
character as something completely
different
it was a blast i think uh you know to be
able to step into a completely different
character after playing a version of
this character for the past two seasons
was so much fun i think as an actor
we're always hoping to challenge
ourselves so it was a real stretch for
me in many ways
and got to sort of explore darker sides
of myself
through exploring this new version of
ben
um but it was also like
mentally and physically and emotionally
draining to be in this headspace for
eight months i mean david knows i was
just
yeah just angry all the time except when
he wasn't eating
you know i mean when he wasn't eating
he's a softy yeah
sure
so david for you was it like you you
were just talking about how
draining it was for justin was it like
cool and interesting to see him take
this on
of course i mean you you go on you read
the lines and you're like oh these are
really funny lines and then justin would
come in and he would just be like
you know and to see him take on that and
be like kind of fearless in his own way
of being like i'm just not going to
treat you the way you expect me i'm
going to treat you because i'm so used
to you know obviously being ben ben
being so like nice and lovable and
welcoming and this guy is like scolding
me and rolling his eyes at me and you
know especially that scene where um
victor and allison go at it and we're
sitting down and you're like eating the
popcorn but in many ways it it really
reflects our actual relationship it is
it does yes
um the other favorite thing and you know
by the time this is out there people
will have seen this
but is that hallucination
right there in the beginning
uh episode one
i understand that doing that sort of a
big scene would be very challenging was
it a lot of fun too
yeah
it was terrifying it was fun it was all
of the emotions yeah you know we had to
rehearse
on zoom during quarantine
and then we finally got in the studio a
couple of weeks before we were supposed
to shoot the scene and
then it was a massive dance-off you know
we learned that you know that circle
thing where everyone's kind of doing
their own dance like that was actually
choreographed by john
and so when we did it on the day
it was like you know it was almost it
felt like a party because you'd be like
all right now you go in there and dance
and everyone was like really like
impressed yeah it was actually yeah it
was the first time we saw everyone's
little dance vignette yeah so it was
really nice
like you see what grace jumped in you
know
say again sorry race mom you know when
grace jumped in and danced to the robot
she did the robot
and then then jordan because that's me
after we did it then she's like upstairs
uh one of the things fans really love
about this show
is how we get to watch the family evolve
we get to watch the hargreaves evolve
season after season and kind of like see
how their relationships move and change
um
with victor coming out this season and
that story being told how important was
it to um
to be respectful and to get that right
well it was very important i mean
you have
you know we're in a time where there's
so much television being made
and some people are a little tone deaf
you know some shows are very toned up of
how they
try to tell a story to the audience
where they don't really know what
they're saying they don't hire the
people that are or should be telling
that story and i think
you know when
when the first thing we found out that
we were going to transition into victor
this year was that they had all these
consultations they had a trans writer
come in and write those specific scenes
to really kind of give a truth
to it and
if you've seen it i've i thought it was
such a beautiful way of just kind of
putting it out there
i also think that
it was
so casual in the best way possible it
didn't need to be this huge thing that
dictated the rest of the season and
it sort of mirrored when elliot shared
with us yeah it was not like
some earth-shattering thing elliott was
always elliot to us and nothing changed
in our relationship to him and yeah he's
still our
family and you see what happens when
there is no pushback because no one in
the brothers and the siblings have
pushback so therefore you start seeing
like oh it's not about this it's
it's about the overall through line of
what the family wants so you know it's
there's something really beautiful about
that yeah yeah absolutely lovely uh
gentlemen thank you so much for the time
congratulations on uh like honestly an
amazing season thank you so much
all the best
you